expert des jeunes vers des maîtres les
visions les masques tombent votez le
masque votre masque vient de tomber
vous l'avez dit vous allez y et braz
politique mais les roulants les urnes ou
franchois différents vous avez traversé
island vous allez vous savez berlin
rapporte qu'il arrêtait vous avez dit si
bien vous ne comprenez rien sur ces
fissures manger dit le coup d'état c'est
bon le coup n'est pas vrai vous avez dit
vous avez dit ça va se régler dans les
yeux rien oui alors alors mais ça va se
régler mais si effectivement ceux qui ne
sont pas contents ils ont un choix ça
t'intéresse vous l'année prochaine
élection qu est-ce qu effectivement de
dire que l'année prochaine nous devrons
choisir et que ceux qui en vivent
estimerait que ce confinement n'est pas
justifié et qu'on nous a gouverné par
l'apport pourront faire un show à l'ailé
à l'arrière
vous n'avez pas nous chercher ne
cherchez pas à confisquer la démocratie
avec moi ne cherchez pas employer des
mots dont vous ne comprenez pas le sens
je pense contredire effectivement mais
n'ayant aucun argument attendait n'ayant
aucun argument à opposer sur les fonds
vous cherchez effectivement exemple
imprimer un calmant pas célébré dans un
cybercafé
[Rires]
mardi non mais pas moi aussi j'aimerais
ça c'est parfait a pris vivant pas je
vais arriver là
non mais vous les offre vous pourrez
voir et tico mais je voulais vous dire
ce qu'il se passe c'est qu'en fait ce
qu'on nous avait demandé si je vous en
prie c'est qui alors je suis triste mais
c'est l'ancien rédacteur en chef du
parena jallieu et oui ça marche pourquoi
j'ai pris avec le parisien alors là
j'ai inscrit sa neuvième année et un
type qui vient qui tutoie le mec il a vu
effectivement faire deux secondes dans
sa vie j'associe à ces voix sylvie
gauthier incarné dans easy cash garcia
au piano dizaine ils ne seront pas la
prochaine course avec plaisir les idées
tutoyé par des vidéos dvi serre et moi
j'en retiens vous félicite ura d'année
prochaine
c'est comme moi vous avez appris ce que
c'était que 15 à l'académie de médecine
bravo